live local now good morning nathan  tylenov in the 8 news now weather center  while sherry's off today two big  developments in the weather first  we're not going to hit 100 today and  tomorrow and  scattered sprinkles nothing really  accumulating we're at 90 degrees not  going to be much change in the  temperature throughout the day today  we're watching humidity and dew point  which are not super high just yet but  probably will increase during the day  light wind we may get very gusty winds  around whatever storms do pop  up we still have the fire weather and  the red flag warnings  a lot of little rain cells moving from  the south to the north maybe a couple of  sprinkles on the west side of town  but really we're not expecting  accumulation i don't even know if we'll  dip into the mid 80s by eight o'clock  certainly in the low 90s at noon only  the mid 90's for the high today and  scattered storms  low 90's by 6 o'clock